На цих кадрах - захоплені російські танки у Святогірську Донецької області, недалеко від Лимана.
Збройні сили України активно наступають на півдні та сході країни.
У деяких місцях відсуваючи супротивника на 30 кілометрів углиб лінії фронту.
Ці українські перемоги є вкрай визначними, зокрема на тактичному і оперативному рівні.
Україна визволила значну кількість населених пунктів.
Крім того, ці успіхи важливі також з огляду на те, що Україна відвойовує території,
про які Росія стверджує, що вони належать до РФ після так званих псевдореферендумів і "анексії".
Тож з кожним квадратним кілометром звільнених Україною територій
достовірність російських фарсових референдумів і фейкової анексії падає.
Тобто кожен квадратний кілометр, який Україна звільняє,
підкреслює слабкість російських позицій не лише на полі бою, але й політично.
Вторгнення Володимира Путіна в Україну провалилося.
Поки що рано оголошувати перемогу, я тут дотримуюся обережнішого підходу,
але докази беззаперечні - ініціатива на сході і на півдні на боці України
і Володимир Путін хоч і оголосив про анексію чотирьох територій,
але його армія навіть не повністю їх контролює.
Причини успішного контрнаступу України - моральний дух військових ЗСУ, західне озброєння,
а також очевидні провали російського командування, вважають військові експерти.
Оголошена Путіним мобілізація має посилити позиції Росії,
але найближчими місяцями ініціатива залишатиметься на боці України.
Ми повинні виходити з того, що матеріальне та чисельне підкріплення,
на яке зараз розраховує російська армія, прибуде лише через два-три місяці.
Це означає, що до цього в Росії будуть великі проблеми, і українці спробують цим скористатися.
Я очікую, що російська сторона посилить повітряні атаки,
оскільки номінальна перевага в цьому на їхньому боці - майже десять до одного.
Росія буде намагатися домогтися кількісної переваги своєї армії, щоб стабілізувати всі завойовані території,
щоб суттєво ускладнити для України контрнаступ на цих територіях.
Тож у довгостроковій перспективі це буде питання кількості проти якості.
Українська армія має кращу якість.
Росія - чим довше триває війна і чим довше триває мобілізація - може отримати перевагу у кількості.
Але знову ж таки: ці російські солдати не є добре оснащеними,
вони або непідготовлені взагалі, або підготовлені недостатньо.
Тож цілком імовірно, що українська перевага - якість - переможе над російською кількістю.
І все ж успіхи українського контрнаступу не варто переоцінювати, вважають експерти.
Поки що рано говорити про те, що ЗСУ зможе незабаром звільнити всі окуповані Росією території.
Але певних успіхів у наступні дні до настання холодів можна очікувати.
Українських сил, звісно, не вистачить, щоб у найближчому майбутньому повністю витіснити росіян з усіх окупованих територій.
Їм не вистачає наступальних озброєнь, тобто танків і бойових машин піхоти, про які зараз постійно говорять.
Крім того, ймовірно, їм також не вистачить загальної ударної потужності, боєприпасів та іншого.
Таким чином їм вдасться відтіснити росіян трохи назад, але потім фронт замре на осінньо-зимовий період.
Перші дощові місяці - листопад, грудень - сповільнять бойові дії,
оскільки багнюка робить будь-які механізовані пересування практично неможливими.
Однак коли ґрунт замерзне, коли настане справжня зима,
є високий шанс, що поле бою знову стане більш мобільним, більш динамічним.
Російська армія, як і раніше, сильна.
Тому малоймовірно, що Україна повністю відвоює всі захоплені Росією території.
Це зараз швидше мрія, ілюзія. Але я можу уявити, що вони просунуться ще далі в Херсоні, а також на північному сході.
Експерти застерігають, що росіяни можуть посилити обстріли української цивільної інфраструктури
або мирних мешканців, як нещодавно поблизу Запоріжжя.
Це можна розцінювати як акт відчаю Путіна, який з усіх сил намагається запобігти колапсу російських військ.
У Путіна є різні опції. Перша опція - надсилати дедалі більше російських чоловіків у цей регіон,
намагаючись стабілізувати ці території, що буде дуже складно.
Інша опція - подальша ескалація атаками на українську цивільну інфраструктуру,
атакуючи також захід країни, приміром, енергетичну інфраструктуру,
щоби продемонструвати, що його погроза, що ці "анексовані" території тепер належать Росії,
насправді не є блефом, як він це сказав у своїй промові.
Експерти погоджуються, що багато в чому ситуація на фронті в Україні залежатиме від підтримки Заходу -
особливо з огляду на нові погрози використання ядерної зброї з боку Росії.
Я стурбований тим, що ми надто радіємо успіхам України та послабимо нашу підтримку,
а наразі не час послаблювати цю підтримку.
Потрібно дати українцям засоби, щоб захистити свою інфраструктуру та дати відсіч цьому вторгненню.
При цьому ми маємо ясно дати зрозуміти, що ми не допустимо нападу на саму Росію,
я, звісно, не маю тут на увазі ці чотири нелегально анексовані українські території.
Невеликий, але все ж таки певний шанс експерти вбачають і в тому,
що в Кремлі може з'явитися усвідомлення, що цю війну не можна виграти,
натомість потрібно починати домовлятися.